In this first final exam problem, we were
tasked with writing the Lexar for a new
programming language. There are seven types of tokens,
and four of which are simple operators. We
have plus, minus, times and divide. So, here
I've written the token rule for the plus
operator. The first line is a regular expression
that matches the plus symbol. And then we return
the token unchanged. And for the rest of the operators,
we're going to follow that same format. We're just going to change
the name of the function and we're going to change the
symbol to which it matches. Our next token is the
identifier. In our programming language, this will be the names
that we have for things. So it can be something
like. My _variable or something even more interesting like just
the word Andy. More precisely, in our program language, an identifier
is a non-empty sequence of letters and underscores, where
the first character is not an underscore. So, we can
write our rule for that pretty simply. Here I
have a function, t_IDENT. And the regular expression is pretty
simple. The first character, and it has to be
at least one character because it's a non-empty string, it's
just going to be some letter. And then we're going
to be followed by zero or more letters or underscores.
So strings in this language are very similar to
strings in Python. We can have single or double quotes,
but in this particular language, for which we are designing
our Lexar, we don't have any escape sequences. This actually
makes the expression to match the strings much simpler. So,
the first rule I'm writing is just for single quoted
strings. The rule for double quoted strings is going to
be very similar. It's just that the right of expression
to which we are matching is going to be slightly different.
When I go over the code at the end and I
show you the finished product, I'll show you what that looks
like. But for now let's just concentrate on single quotas strings. Here
I require that the string begins and ends with a single
quote and is a sequence of zero or more, kind of
an empty string, characters that aren't the single quote. Since we
don't have escape characters that's all we need. So here I'm taking
out the quotes from the beginning and end of
the string, that way the value of this token is
the string itself. And I'm setting the type to
string. All caps. Numbers in this language are a little
bit different than Python. First off, the only numbers
we have are positive integers. So negative 5, and 5.5
are both not valid numbers in this language. So, one
example of a good one would be 5, we're also
allowed to put underscores anywhere in the number, as long as it's not the first
character in the number. So, 5_5 _ _ _ is going to be
equivalent to just 55. A lot of languages actually have
this feature because it's easier to read 1, 2, 3, _, 4, 5, 6. Similar
to how we often put a 123,456.
So here I've started writing out the token rule
for numbers in this language. The first character has to
be a digit, zero thru nine. And afterwards we
can have zero or more digits or underscores. Now we
want the value of the number token to be
the number, the integer, that it represents. However if we
just return the string, or try to call some. Integer
conversion on it, we're just going to get a lot
of underscores and it's not really going to work
and it's not what we want. We want to take 5_5_
_ _ and just get 55. So, my strategy
is going to be to go through each character in
our string, append any digits to a new string,
ignore any underscores. And once I'm done call ent onto
that string, to get the integer that the original token
represented. So, here I have the finished function. I want to
go through each character like I planned. If it's
not an underscore I'm going to append it onto our
temp string and then call ent on that temp
string to get the new value. And here I
have the finished code. We have our basic operators,
plus, minus, times, and divide, the identifier function we
wrote, single and double strings, [UNKNOWN] the only difference
here is that we have single quotes right here,
double quotes right there. And lastly, the number token function that we wrote.